when Russia's bombardments of Mario Paul
intensified earlier in the year hundreds
surrendered to Russian bat forces at
steel works in the city John Harding was
one of them now free after a prisoner
exchange he may be away from the darkest
days he experienced during this war but
they're not behind him here he describes
one of the worst beatings he experienced
I was lying on the floor with my hands
cooked behind my back
and I was kicked in the in the chest
ribs kidneys
um in my um in my face
and uh you know and one guy was actually
stood on my hips from Death on me for a
while that lasted about about 30 minutes
but it could have been longer could have
been um shorter to be honest like it was
a few times I I was to just scheduled
with
if you're going to be killed better just
get it all with
on an emotional level do you think
you've even begun to process what you've
been through uh uh no
obviously I can't speak for it with the
people but for me it's
uh
at the most plural Quest
we go from joking about your experiences
John says guards often beat him for fun
leaving him with numerous injuries he
suffered nerve damage to his hands has
several cracked ribs his sternum
detached from his rib cage and he has a
broken coccyx his sister Denise
described the day he came home
when he came into the room he looked
okay
looks alright and then I realized the
damage they're done
he took off his top because
Durkin and I could see the ribs and I
could see this bone
and his hands were
the damaging him I knew then
and that's what I give him the biggest
hug
I just said
just such a child sorry what what have
they done to you
just like those he returned with John's
focusing on his recovery but no doubt
he'll be left with scars that last a
lifetime I shazid Sky News in
Hertfordshire